I'm starting to live as the co-director
of
Hellenic studies program here at Yale
and I would like to welcome Michael
Dukakis who is the speaker tonight for
the annual Stavros Niarchos foundation
lecture which is our main event were
very pleased to have him tonight and
we're also very grateful to the
starbursts Negros foundation for funding
this lecture and also funding our
program and I would like to call mr.
Vasilis Thomas to say a few words on
behalf the power of the of the
foundation and then I'll come back and
present the governor it's it's a great
pleasure to be with you tonight here
it's a particular privilege and honor I
was born and raised in Greece so the
connectivity is immediate and serious
I'm represented here the Stavros
Niarchos foundation is the chief
operating officer the Stavros Niarchos
and I'm a numbers guy so it's
established 22 years ago in have given
over two and a half billion dollars in
some hundred and twenty-five countries
around the world with some 5000 grands
the Yale relationship is going back to
16 years if not more it is a very
meaningful multifaceted relationship in
the School of Art in the Hellenic
studies in the School of Medicine the
School of Public Affairs and we are
delighted to continue supporting in any
way we can as we do always in arts and
culture education social welfare health
medicine and sports which is a broad
mandate for our foundation that we are
proud to continue our founder has given
us particular direction to give at least
half of what we give towards Greek
causes and we are proud to continue that
we have offices around the world that
would do this effectively we have gone
through some difficult times in Greece
as you all know
we had some very severe headwinds when
there was nothing that could be done
they told us we had something to do we
thought so we supported through
humanitarian support with three waves of
300 million euros each and very many
causes the immediate needs that the
country had and we thought I will give a
small light of Hope in the abyss and
darkness of the reality in Greece by
building a cultural center a educational
center a recreational center in Athens
it was a large project of over 800
million dollars that we delivered to the
Greek state and we are delighted that
over a million people had visited
already in the first year of operations
having that in mind I don't want to hold
you back from the excellent speaker that
we have so I will ask dr. Collins to
come back I thank you very much for your
hospitality
[Applause]
thank you very much and thank you very
much for your continuing support so it's
a great pleasure and honor for us to
welcome Michael Dukakis here at Yale for
this annual lecture governor Dukakis is
presently a colleague of sorts he's a
professor of political science at
Northeastern University so I'm very
pleased by that but of course he's very
widely known for for his political
career that spans a very very long time
in a way one can say he's a living
history of American politics of the last
40 years Michael Stanley Dukakis was
born in Brookline Massachusetts both of
his parents were immigrants from Greece
and he grew up in Boston he studied at
Swarthmore College and then went to
Harvard Law School and after serving in
the military in the US military
he began very early on a stellar
political career he started in 1970 he
started initially in fact in the
nineteen sixties serving in local
positions and then in 1970 he was
nominated as the Massachusetts he was
the nominee for the Massachusetts
Democratic Party for the position of
lieutenant government government
governor of Massachusetts he didn't win
that election there is a very
interesting nonlinear political career
but then he came back in 1978 in 1974 he
was elected as a governor was defeated
after the end of his first term he had
to serve under very adverse economic
conditions but then after being away for
four years he was elected and then he
was elected again for a second term so
altogether he served as three-term
governor of Massachusetts with this
interruption in the middle however the
reason he is nationally known
in the united states is because in 1988
he was nominated by the democratic party
to be the candidate of the party in the
presidential election of that year he
faced george bush the senior and he was
defeated in that election but it's
really his participation in that
election that brought him national
attention after that he finished his
service as governor of massachusetts and
decided not to go back into active
politics his career since then spans
both academic work and policy work he's
been a faculty at Northeastern
University in Boston as I said in
political science and he has also served
in various positions in policy including
most notably on the board of directors
of Amtrak which is very interesting and
he has been also an observer and
commentator of American politics trying
to understand the various developments
in that area and that's precisely what
he's going to talk to us about tonight I
would like to highlight by way of
connecting myself to him two moments and
two memories which come together in the
summer of 1988 this was when having won
a Fulbright scholarship as an
undergraduate in Greece I came to study
in the United States I was accepted at
the University of Chicago as a PhD
student I had never been in the United
States before that was my first time and
Fulbright actually sent me to California
at the University of California Davis
for an orientation program so I arrived
in Sacramento never having been in the
United States before and of course that
was the summer of 1988 presidential
campaign
I remember that campaign very very
vividly because it was the first major
political event I witnessed in the in
the United States and one of the things
that I remember at the time which was
quite shocking was the extent to which
Michael Dukakis had to face a very
negative campaign from the Republican
side in hindsight we know that that was
beginning of a turn in American politics
in which what we may describe as nasty
polarizing political campaigning gained
a lot of traction and the fact that it
was successful that it worked for the
Republicans at the time certainly gave
that new mix of policy of political
strategies a lot of traction in American
politics for worse however the the thing
that is really striking of course is
when we look back at those times what
appears to have been extremely negative
and very nasty pales in comparison to
what we're experiencing today and I'd be
very interested to hear governor Dukakis
his thoughts about that evolution its
causes potential consequences the second
thing that I would like to mention is
that for me arriving in the United
States for the first time at that
particular juncture I remember very
vividly every time I was interacting
with an American they would ask me where
I'm from I would say from Greece and
then they would say Michael Dukakis and
and for me that was an incredibly
welcoming reaction for a variety of
reasons first of all because they felt
that being Greek was not something
trivial in fact a person from my
homeland was presidential candidate n
surely the next president of the United
States the second thing was that it gave
me the feeling that this was a country
that could turn the son of immigrants
into a president and therefore it gave
me a sense that this could be a home
this was a welcoming country diverse
country that gave a lot of opportunities
to the people who came to their short
whitshire and so I am very grateful and
very glad after 30 years that was in
1988
to take this opportunity to thank you
for making me so welcome when I arrived
from the first time the United States so
I'm very happy to welcome you tonight
here for this annual lecture thanks for
coming
[Applause]
this will be less a lecture more I hope
an informal and interesting discussion
which is why the way I tried to teach
anyway so I couldn't deliver a lecture
from a script if I if I tried but I'm
glad that I made you welcome even if I
wasn't conscious about it the support I
got from the Greek community during that
election was extraordinary and some of
you were here and I'm very grateful to
all of you who are part of this I'm not
sure I'm gonna be able to do to say
anything definitive tonight about how we
try to deal with our problems in a
bipartisan way but it's very interesting
I just had my 84th birthday I feel like
a million bucks and my dear mother who
came here at the age of nine with her
family and settled in Haverhill
Massachusetts shoe town in those days
and so far as we can determine was the
first Greek young woman ever to go away
to college unless courted in the history
of the United States never happened
before thanks to an elementary school
principal named Stanley gray if you want
to know why my middle name is Stanley
and not my father's which is the Greek
tradition as most of you know it's
because my mother wanted one of her sons
to carry that name and he became a
second father to her her father was a
guy who had great respect for educators
and mr. gray was very very important
person in in the family life and so this
little Greek girl not only finished high
school itself unusual but went away -
Bates College
unless courted never happened before and
graduated Phi Beta Kappa 1925 she was
born and grew up in Latin my dad whose
people were from et leaning from lesbos
actually grew up in a predominantly
Greek town in western Turkey it was
called either Dimitri the grief college
the methi Matar Scala dead remote town
of about 12,000 75% Greek at the time
and he was born in 1896 and when he was
15 in 1912 and I don't know if this had
anything to do with the young turk
movement which was obviously beginning
to become very important in Turkey but
the age of 15 he decided to want to come
to the United States to get an education
now as many of you know in those days
young Greeks didn't come here to get an
education on the most part they came
here to get a job but this 15 year old
decided he want to come here and get an
education he had two brothers who were
working in the textile mills and Lowell
and Lawrence didn't speak a word of
English didn't have a nickel in his
pocket and twelve years laters you just
heard my dad graduated from Harvard
Medical School how he did it I have no
idea folks worked in the mills worked in
restaurants went to night school went to
Boston University for a year itself very
unusual and met another Greek a guy
named Zuri fees somehow convinced him
that the two of them ought to become
doctors those days I didn't eat it was
two years of free medical and somehow
they ended up at Bates now this is long
before my mother was there it had no
connection to do one year of pre-medical
he did all their science stuff and he
wanted to go to Harvard Medical School
and he was put on the waiting list it
was very very disappointed and he ended
up at Dartmouth which in those days was
a two-year medical school from which you
transferred to some other medical school
and with a very heavy heart he went up
to Hanover they showed him his room said
this was Daniel Webster's room my father
I'm gonna - we knew who Daniel Webster
wasn't any event he didn't care and a
week later he got a telegram from his
mother family have settled in Lowell
saying come home Harvard Medical s
admitted you did for medical school
internships residences and practice
medicine for 52 years at 4:54 Huntington
Avenue for those of you
with geography lesson right across the
Museum of Fine Arts interestingly enough
that apartment building is it was at
that time and where my parents spent the
first three years of their married life
it's now Burstein Holland Northeastern
University wherever in teaching 26 years
so when people say to me up a boost then
you know grace I say a meeting in your
see me because I see a tease you me
ladies sales game he may he be Rockies
because my maternal grandparents came
from a little village called visa hoodie
in in a Paris and then the folks in
Corfu decided to make me an honorary
citizen so I added a fifth daughter
you may call for your keys but it's a
great header urgent heritage
thanks to my guy on my father's side
didn't speak a word of English and lived
us for the first seven years of our of
my life I grew up bilingual you know I
speak pretty good seven-year-old Greek
but I as I said the folks when we were
meeting when I go to Greece and Kitty
and I try to go there we once every
three years or so and they put me on
television I say to them Dinah calm
Mooney poorly apply you then echo Alexi
wouldn't econ Costolo
so they have to put me in English with
subtitles so that is fortunately I fell
in love with a wonderful woman who's
with us tonight and in her own right has
done extraordinary advocacy particularly
the field of mental health and refugees
and immigrants worked as a social worker
professionally with refugees and
immigrants and I always introduced her
as the best looking Medicare recipient
in America she is but she's here with us
tonight Kitty Dukakis there we go
she's about to have her 81st birthday so
we're gonna have a big celebration Katie
was born the day after Christmas which
is always a difficult thing and now we
celebrate Christmas with our son and his
family and bus and our daughters are in
Denver and San Francisco and eat you
have a couple of kids so they swap
birthday celebrations and then we drag
ourselves off to UCLA for the winter
quarter it's a terrible burden but
somebody's got to do it and and we've
had a really remarkable thing and they
are just beginning a Hellenic studies
program there and I hope I'm gonna be at
least in my three months involved with
that so what you folks have done here
really is a mom model for us and the
Greek community and in Los Angeles was
very enthusiastic about about the new
Hellenic studies program at UCLA that
very generous and very supportive and
and we're looking forward to it so what
about bipartisanship was America a kind
of center of bipartisanship over the
course of its political career the
answer to that question is absolutely
not yeah that campaign in 88 where I
should have done a much better job of
feeling that attack campaign that I did
was pretty nasty and I did a terrible
job of responding to it and I had been
through some very tough negative
campaigns in my gubernatorial races so
it wasn't if this was a new phenomenon
but I made what turned out to be a
pretty done decision and that was that I
was not going to respond to the to the
attack campaign and one of my closest
colleagues among the nation's governors
was Mario Cuomo a guy I admired
enormously and when we were talking
about the race initially he said look
forget about that yeah don't worry about
this attack stuff just ignore it it's
not gonna it's not going to affect
anything we were campaigning together
four days before the election in
November of 88 in Queens he turned to me
says the worst advice I ever gave you
but
I responded to it because I think like
Mario were positive people we're not
interested in acting like a couple of
kids in the sandbox only sanity each
other and we just turned out to be the
wrong strategy which was very vulnerable
the most liberal furlough program in
America was the Reagan Bush furlough
program in the federal prison system
they were throwing people for 45 days
one of their Louie's when I was burdened
a young pregnant mother in the southwest
I like I saw I never said that
well you don't respond to that kind of
stuff folks it's gonna take its toll so
I apologize to wall of a I used to say
about beatin Bush one you never heard of
Bush to because I thought Bush two was
the worst president I'd ever lived under
until this this guy came along more on
that later and it is not true that the
United States has been a haven of
bipartisan politics the politics of this
country immediately after the
declaration of independence and the
ratification the Constitution were
brutal and even the press made no
pretense of being objective
in fact when Jefferson left the
presidency after eight years he said
something about finally being able to
get the jackals of the press office back
or words of that effect
it was brutal it was very tough and
every once in while these days people
say to me well have you ever seen it
this bad and I say to them did you see
the movie Lincoln I mean that was bad
American politics have been rough and in
many cases quite partisan partisan and
we've gone through some very very
difficult periods I don't have any of
you familiar with what happened in this
country right after World War one when
we had domestic terrorism far in excess
of anything that we've ever experienced
what was going on I mean you know what
was going on at that time especially in
major northeastern cities terrorists
many of them anarchists were blowing up
cities regularly in fact one of them
blew up the home of the Attorney General
this guy Palma who subsequently wants
the so called Palmer Raids
and was a graduate of North Laurel
College can I believe it a graduate of a
Quaker institution being involved in
this kind of thing and in point of fact
Sacco and Vanzetti went to chip went to
the one of the electric chair folks not
because they committed that crime they
didn't but because they were Italian
immigrants and they happen to be
anarchists now they weren't violent
anarchist they had never engaged in any
violent activity but there isn't any
questions those folks are convicted
because they were southern Europeans
tensions on and so forth and and those
Palmer Raids were a response to regular
terrorist attacks in major American
cities especially east of the
Mississippi I'm trying to think of maybe
a time or two when the United States was
a haven for bipartisan activity and
there's no question that we've had some
of those situations but I was at
Swarthmore from 1951 to 1955 that's when
a guy when you named Joseph R McCarthy
was doing his thing it was a terrible
time folks and McCarthy had his
supporters so I'm at Swarthmore and this
Greek kid at a Quaker College I had
never been out of New England I didn't
know a Quaker from a shaker I had no
idea what this was all about but I knew
it was pretty good school I want to get
out of New England and I thought about
going to Bates my brother was there but
he said you know you like cities so why
don't you take a look at Swarthmore I
said isn't that a girl school he said
though that's Skidmore
I mean that's how much we know but it
was these were four very important years
for me and I got quite active
politically and within six weeks after I
graduated in 1955 I was drafted in the
United States Army and showed up at the
Fargo building in Boston with 30 other
characters and we got on a train and we
went to Fort Dix New Jersey for a first
eight weeks of basic training three
weeks three days after we got there
three days after we got there we had
what passed for a personnel interview
five minutes in front of another draftee
it was a personnel specialist so-called
who decided what you would do for the
next two years
except my guy had a file on mate
this is in pre-computer America with
every single political activity I had
ever engaged in a saloon or college so
the interview went something like this
so I see you
we ran a fundraising drives the American
Civil Liberties Union while you're on
the South Laurel campus yeah as a matter
of fact I did and you were the chairman
of students for democratic action which
was a student wing of the a DA the
Liberal Democratic organization
otherwise succeeded in that capacity of
Swarthmore a guy named Carl Levin who
just finished 18 years in the United
States Senate from Michigan I said yeah
as a matter of fact I was and we went
through this thing now I was a little
concerned folks because I knew people
who had been drafted and they'd been
held for months and in some cases
discharged dishonorably or other than
honorably because of some organization
that they had joined when they're in
high school one of them happened to be a
dear friend of mine who had joined
something called the United world
Federalist wasn't left it wasn't right
it was basically for a strong UN and
that guy spent three or four months
before his father was able to get ahold
of Paul Douglas and Dick Neuberger and
both United States senators who managed
to make it possible for him to serve the
military and then went to medical school
and there's been a doctor to community
health center for many many years in
Boston and I'm not sure I decided at the
time I wanted to go into politics
professionally but was kind of the back
of my head and I wasn't interested in
in my political career with another than
honorable discharge needless to say
anyway now fortunately the guy didn't
recommend that and sent me to Korea
which was okay how do you think the
government got that information on this
Greek kid from Boston who had just spent
four years at a small college outside of
Philadelphia ten years later we
discovered that the FBI had a tap of a
Swarthmore switchboard was recording
every single phone call as we did
switchboard and apparently had somebody
that you and I were paying taking notes
to come up with files on that guy it was
a terrible terrible period folks and
there were no neutrals you read the
probe McCarthy or Andy McCarthy Vietnam
was worse if there at least some of you
old enough to remember during that
period it was families were divided
friends were divided
there was nothing bipartisan about that
war so we've been here before now the
fact that we have somebody in the White
House who's charitably what a little
strange
obviously colors.this and when I was at
Swarthmore I don't know how many
political scientists we have in the room
there was a guy at Wesleyan named shot
Snyder
any folks who shot Snyder's then they
mean anything to any of you one personal
bank one two yeah shot Snyder was
arguing that the United States and its
politics weren't partisan enough you had
Liberal Democrats and conservative
Democrats in the South who pretty much
controlled the Congress as a result of
any seniority and they never voted
together you had conservative
Republicans and liberal Republicans lot
of especially in the Northeast folks
that I worked with very closely good
people shared the same values and so on
and so forth but what did it mean to be
a Republican what
mean to be a Democrat when you had
conservatives and liberals in the same
party shot Snyder argued very forcefully
it was time to turn the parties into
organizations it stood for something and
we did it
and now we're very under self but shot
Snyder's thesis it was calling the shots
NightA thesis was what that what's the
point of going in and voting Democratic
or republican if you don't know what's
going to happen when it's all over and
remember the conservative Democrats were
largely from the south and blatantly
segregationist and racist and one of the
great partisan battles in this country
was the civil rights revolution in which
we finally decided that least we hope we
decided that color of somebody's skin
was not something that I didn't put that
person too horribly inferior position
and we're still working at it still
working at it even as this country gets
browner burner and apparently that's
bothering some folks cuz Charlotte's
filled no I don't think we should take
it overly seriously but charles phil was
a reflection of the fact that there are
people out there who who apparently have
very very my opinion dangerous and
biased opinions and they were obviously
reflected to some extent and in this guy
that's currently in the white house all
this by way of background we've gone
through lots and lots of partisan
battles in this country the question is
what do we do about it now and the short
answer to it as far as I'm concerned is
I'm not sure now at the state and local
level at least in my experience there's
much less partisanship its partisan and
there are ideological differences but
there must be some reason why the
nation's mayor's most of Democrats with
some Republicans seem to come together
around a common agenda and I think it's
because they're all
the same kinds of problems some of my
closest colleagues in the National
Governors Association Dan Evans from
Washington who taught me a lot as a
rookie governor thoughtful progressive
and more than willing to reach out to us
young guys had just showed up in the
organization and extremely helpful there
was at the time a new generation of
young white democratic governors in the
south who were Pro civil rights let me
tell you folks that took a lot of guts
who were they well it started with a guy
named Bill winter in Mississippi a
remarkable guy still going strong at 93
and then there were guys like Clinton
Bob Graham and Florida dick Riley who I
just talked to the other day in South
Carolina a wonderful guy but Lamar
Alexander a Republican who were Pro
civil rights and got themselves elected
in the south but that whole struggle
which continues was not fun folks and in
point of fact the civil rights
revolution itself in many cases was
violent people lost their lives and and
the politics around race were brutal so
what do we do about this well here's
what I teach my kids at Swarthmore
having at Northeastern these days and I
spent a lot of time talking about how
you try to build consensus in politics
and get things done because you can't
get things done in politics without
building consensus it took me 20 years
to figure that out and a defeat for
re-election the first time to kind of
wake up to this first now he does defeat
so vo a little bit but it makes you a
much better listener I was a pretty good
talker when I went into politics I
wasn't
listener and after being defeated for
election that first time I started
listening to people more and I
discovered two things first listening is
less tiring than talking and secondly
you learn stuff and after about twenty
years of this business I finally began
to get the hang of it so what do I teach
my students these days about trying to
build consensus first that you go out
and identify all of the key people I
hate this word stakeholder because
nobody knows what it means but yeah I
call them key players and you bring them
together in the form of a working group
now you've got to keep it reasonably
reasonably sized a working group of whom
of people interested in the issue many
of whom can't stand each other's guts
when the process begins and it's
remarkable what happens folks when you
bring people together especially if you
are a prominent office holder sit them
down
with good staff who understands how to
do this and begin to go to work and see
if you can identify agreement around
common problems and I want to talk about
this in the context of health care in
this country which has been occupying us
for a long time we're the only advanced
industrialized nation in the world that
does not provide comprehensive health
care for all of its people and as you
can see from this I'll get to the tax
bill in a second which i think is the
most unbelievable piece of legislation
I've ever seen in my life but and and
seeks to weaken the Affordable Care Act
again if you want to take a poll
tomorrow
among the American people and ask them
should working Americans and their
families have decent affordable health
care what do you think the numbers look
like
93% say yes and the other seven haven't
thought about serious
and the vast majority of uninsured
people in this country are working on
members of working families they're not
loafing they're not sitting around
they're not on public assistance we're
on welfare you get medicaid he's a
working Americans no health care and
when they get so sick that they can't
stand up they end up in the emergency
room and we're all pampered in the form
of increased premiums and increased
taxes 93% say yes now I was a fan of
Barack Obama's I want to talk a little
bit about the foreign policy side of
this bipartisanship and I and he worked
very hard in this but he never really in
this case delivered a message which I
think and as a guy that put up universal
health care bill through his state
legislature did constantly talking about
working Americans and their families not
having decent affordable health care
Americans like people will work and
they're appalled by the notion that
working Americans their families can't
have decent affordable health care so
this very broad agreement across this
country about that and so the
interesting question is why is it become
so partisan an issue I'm not gonna
criticize the former president who got
elected twice I couldn't even get it
once I got a lot of respect for him
politically in otherwise but I do think
that message a this is about working
Americans this is about working
Americans they have families would have
resonated more than we're gonna get rid
of pre-existing conditions and he can
keep the kids in the policy until
they're 26 it seemed to me that was the
central message which by the way neither
the administration nor the Democrats in
Congress seemed to focus on and I
finally got so upset at one point that I
called the White House I don't do this
very often
of course these days I don't do it at
all but back in those days and I talked
to the young woman who was handling
press for the on the health care bill
and I said to her hey look I've got a
great respect for your boss I mean he
got elected twice I couldn't even go
elected once
but I did put a universal healthcare
bill through my legislature and I said
it must have had 200 press events and
there was always a working person or
working family next to me at that podium
talking about what it was like to try to
live and work of sports herself and her
family without decent health insurance
and she said to me what's your source
for that I said 85% of the uninsured
bhima's country a working members
working family she said what's your
source for that I said it's the Census
Bureau worst via bus so about two days
later President Obama mentioned working
people for the first time in discussion
health care and she called me and said
you see what the president said I said
yeah but he's got to say it 20 times a
day and so the Congress didn't happen
could we have gotten bipartisan support
of a health care bill that emphasized
the importance of providing health care
to working folks in their families don't
know don't know but that wasn't the
central theme unfortunately and message
is important folks that's another lesson
you learn from getting your head handed
to you in your first run for election
I don't know folks at this point that
it's possible to somehow get back to
that day when we had notwithstanding
professor shot Schneider liberal or
progressive or whatever you want to call
a moderate Republicans and Democrats who
who managed to get some stuff done could
Medicare today pass this Congress I
doubt it very much I doubt it very much
this tax bill I'm sorry I'm the son of
Greek immigrants if I heard the words
economía mija do you gonna be me honey
once I heard him a thousand times a
Greeks wastes nothing right worth 50 we
economize does anybody know what the
current u.s.
budget deficit is just this year what is
it 700 billion dollars and we're close
to full employment there were better
economists in this room that I am I'm
not an economist but I'm sorry we're
close to full employment but this time
we ought to have a surplus a guy named
Clinton you remember him in his last
State of the State address State of the
Union address proposed a plan which he
said credibly would reduce and eliminate
the national debt in 10 to 12 years that
was at a time when we had a surplus of a
quarter of a trillion dollars first time
that had happened in 50 years under a
democratic administration and the
Republicans at the time in Congress
wanted a tax cut we had full employment
in those days and I think the economists
will agree that you don't cut taxes when
you have full employment you got to
start worrying about inflation a few
other things and when the pollsters went
out and asked the American people this
was in the year 2000 whether they will
for the president's plan or they wanted
a tax cut they said forget about the tax
cut by two-to-one do what the
president's talking about what was he
talking about putting money away for
Social Security 2035 anticipating
contingencies doing the kinds of stuff
that responsible people tend to do under
these circumstances why are we talking
about a tax cut when we have a budget
deficit of 700 billion dollars and we're
close to full employment this is
absolutely insane folks I'm sorry I mean
forget about the bill itself which is
you know back to giving tax cuts to the
wealthy and trickle-down economics
didn't work the first time we're gonna
try it again
but I'm sorry I mean how do you if you
if you're and frankly I'm not hearing a
lot about the budget deficit from the
Democrats
they don't like the tax cut they think
it ought to be into the middle class I'm
sorry you know most of us a middle class
there's no room at this point my
judgment in American economic policy for
a tax cut for the middle class we've got
to get this budget deficit eliminate it
and start running some surpluses if
we're at full employment otherwise sorry
to say this we're gonna start looking
more like Greece and its troubles I mean
this this budget this this build is
gonna give us a current an operating
deficit of a trillion and a half dollars
any of you know what we're spending on
debt service right now every year just
to pay the interest on 20 trillion
dollars in debt remember the Clinton
plan we've eliminated it in fact at the
time Alan Greenspan was the chairman of
the Federal Reserve and he he he wasn't
against it but he was troubled he said
well if you don't have some debt how can
the Fed works the Clinton said we'll
give you it you know half a trillion
dollars in debt will so you can do your
thing why are we spending just to
service the national debt every year
anybody know 500 billion dollars half a
trillion dollars just for interest on
this debt that we piled up you go to a
trillion and a half folks and about a
third of the federal budget is going to
be paying interest I think that's very
bad policy and I'm not sure how given
what appears to be now virtual unanimity
in the part of the Republicans in the
Senate and a substantial majority in the
house I don't know how you figure that
one out on a bipartisan basis I mean
sure the Democrats have been talking
more about fiscal responsibility which
unfortunately my party doesn't do as
much as it should should we've been
trying to explain to the American people
that that this is serious and very
flawed economic policy I'm not sure how
one solves that problem
the bipartisan basis if 52 Republican
senators now have kind of lined up for
this and this was the party which to its
credit used to talk about fiscal
responsibility until Dick Cheney came
along and said Reagan proved that
deficits don't matter I'm here to tell
you I think deficits matter it's not
that you don't want to run them from
time to time especially if you're in
deep trouble economically but if you
have a trillion and a half dollar debt
folks and we go into another recession
you tell me where we're gonna find the
resources to get out of that one well
this is just crazy so what's the answer
to all of this you look for at least
some issues where you can find common
ground
I may be an optimist I am an optimist
you can't be in politics and be a
definite pessimist you don't think that
good people working together can make a
difference in the lives of their fellow
citizens and don't go into politics but
I think there are some issues and I
think there was an opportunity they
incidentally you all know that Richard
Nixon proposed a very good health care
plan right and if you anybody old enough
to remember that except me
wasn't Universal Medicare but it was a
comprehensive universal plan in which
employers and employees would have to
contribute to health care at the
workplace all of them without exception
75 percent employer 25 percent employee
with a somewhat expanded Medicaid
program for people that were temporarily
unemployed that was a Nixon plan if Ted
Kennedy were here today to tell you the
worst political mistake he ever made was
in not supporting that plan because with
Kennedy's support the sport of Labor and
the Liberals who have gone through
Congress lifelike enough knife through
butter and it wasn't until they tried to
get universal Medicare and couldn't that
they find decided to sit down with
Nixon's people and a young assistant
secretary named Stuart almond who's been
teaching at Brandeis for many many years
and came up with a plan which would have
through Congress except for something
called Watergate and once Watergate hit
and Nixon's presidency was destroyed
that was the end of the Nixon plan one
state in the United States decided to
pass a state version of the Nixon plan
what state was that not Massachusetts
that came later
state of Hawaii little Hawaii out there
I remember when Dan Quayle was asked
about the Hawaiian healthcare plan and
you know like most folks in Washington
he had never heard of the Hawaiian
elegant plan but it was a state version
of the Nixon plan and it's been
operating Hawaii since 1975 virtually
universal coverage some of the best
health hub health outcomes in America in
little Hawaii nobody knows about it
nobody cares about in Washington for
reasons I don't understand but the Nixon
plan would have been an excellent health
plan and it would have cover everybody
and we wouldn't be going through this
crazy debate could we get back to that
with this Congress support the Nixon
plan No why not why not because it has
an employer and an employee mandate but
you can't have universal health care
folks unless all of us are required to
contribute something now when it comes
to folks at 65 and older we're fortunate
in the 60s we passed Medicare does it
include a mandate course it includes a
mandate you're paying a piece of your
wage every time you get it for Social
Security and Medicare right and
employers have to do the same what
Medicare goes through this Congress I
kind of doubt it
are there opportunities for bipartisan
cooperation yes but in some cases and I
want to conclude with this that may be
dangerous I
know how you folks feel about American
foreign policy these days I'm very upset
about it and I'm upset about it under
both Republican and Democratic
presidents because this country cannot
be the world's policeman with rare
exceptions our military intervention
since World War two have been disastrous
and if we don't get serious about
building an international framework for
resolving international differences and
I'm serious about this I'm not a
romantic about the you and I just think
you know back in my math email right one
of my favorite Greek sayings right
things happen you're supposed to learn
from them I don't see how you can look
at what's happened since World War two
and not conclude that that this world of
ours needs strong international
organization in which the United States
participates actively and not just to
deal with problems in North Korea which
were resolved toward the end of the
Clinton administration you know with a
plan that the North Koreans bought into
before they had nukes and unfortunately
was essentially torpedoed by the Bush
administration that followed but the
deal with climate change may be the very
existence of the planet and other
regional disputes that will flare up
from time to time so in that sense this
kind of bipartisan support for a u.s.
role which seems to me to be anything
but a success these days and in fact is
causing more problems not fewer doesn't
strike me as being a good bipartisan
solution I want to know where the people
in my party are who concerned about this
or a mic kind of an outlier who is in
his old age getting crazy ideas I don't
think so folks I don't think so so
here's a place not where we want people
to be baldly partisan but it's time for
some debate over American foreign policy
and American defense policy which among
other things is now in the process of
spending a trillion dollars to modern
our nuclear arsenal and that was the
product of the Obama administration now
of course enthusiastically supported by
the new guy in the White House maybe you
think we ought to be spending a trillion
dollars to modernize a nuclear arsenal I
think we got to be working our heads off
to eliminate nuclear weapons and in that
respect and and that on that issue Henry
Kissinger agrees with me anyway
lots of things going on out there and I
want to stop at this point and open up
things for discussion and feel free to
be as critical as you want because
that's one of the things the Greeks
brought to society the idea of debate
discussion so forth but let me just say
a word or two if I can quickly to the
young people that are here I'm a little
concerned these days I'm not seeing
enough young Greek Americans getting
actively involved in politics there was
a time several years ago when John Brad
amis and Paul sarbanes and myself and a
bunch of others were were doing things
and I hope inspiring young Greeks to go
in but I'm not seeing enough of that
these days folks and let me say this too
when pericles talked about citizenship
in athens and what the obligation of
citizens to be deeply and actively
involved in the political process and
and when he criticized athenians who
were not doing that that's a belief that
that i share and have been inspired by
for a long time there's nothing like
being a public service and being in a
position where you can make a difference
in the lives of your fellow citizens and
Kenny and I have had the great good
fortune to be able to do that all of our
lives and with one exception the fact
that I never made it to the left go
eagle it's been an incredible ride and
we're still at it my mother used to say
that if you want to live a long life
pick your parents carefully
she lived till she was a hundred and
kitty's devs conducting the busting pops
when he was 94 so we're planning to
stick around for a while but I want to
see more and more and more young Greek
Americans getting involved in politics
and I hope you'll do that and if there's
anything I can do to be helpful just
calling me and I'm serious because I'd
like nothing more to be in a position
where I can provide you with whatever
guidance I can when it comes to this
kind of thing okay I'm gonna stop at
this point we've got some time questions
comments reactions criticism fire away
who's first
wants to start this discussion go ahead
yeah you know well it would have been
worse on the other hand having
experienced the social media and what it
does and doesn't do obviously we would
have been ready for it and equipped to
go at it now having said that the
channel is a challenge here folks when
you're running for office and somebody's
coming at you with this stuff and I had
a very rough fight when I lost for
reelection the first time and came back
in one the second time those were not
lovely peaceful campaigns either one of
them how do you blunt the attacks
without turning itself into an attacker
and then about two weeks people say were
fed up with both of these guys now I was
able to do that successfully because we
didn't have social media in 1982 when I
ran against this guy King was the second
time it beat him but it wasn't a nice
campaign fortunately for me he had run a
pretty sleazy administration and he was
coming at me because in my first term I
had signed the biggest tax increase in
Massachusetts history because the state
was broke I don't know who it was
I wasn't jeez and came up with this idea
but in any event we came back at him by
saying well he may not have raised your
taxes but you're paying a huge
corruption tax as a result of this guy
and it seemed to work and at the same
time people I think thought I was
justified in doing that but that's it's
a fine line that you draw here between
you know getting into the muck so you're
just as bad as the other guy and trying
to maintain some standards in some
integrity while well blunting these
attacks but to go back to your question
I mean in this era you got to be ready
for that stuff all the time all the time
who's next yeah not getting the message
across but the polling shows that the
people don't like the tax plan they get
it it's the politicians who don't seem
to care that we don't like it well some
of them like it because they're voting
for it like 52 of them apparently
well 52 politicians like them are they
listening their constituents has has the
Democratic might have done an effective
job of explaining what's in this plan
I'm not sure we have have we pointed out
to people that were currently running a
deficit of 700 billion dollars it's
gonna increase the national debt by
another 700 billion dollars I'm not
hearing that are you I don't think
people nobody's talking about the
national fiscal state of affairs here
nobody it's all a question of as I said
it's all a question of what tax cut the
alike Democrats say well a lot to be for
the middle class sorry with all due
respect the middle class we're all
middle class aren't we most of us
there's no room for tax cut at this
point we've got to get that deficit out
of there and fast before we hit another
recession and then have no fiscal
flexibility look one of the reasons is
we were able to get out of the Great
Recession folks was because there was
some fiscal flexibility there although
Bush had squandered the surplus and got
us into a war that's gonna cost us
retuning treat three trillion dollars
still going on by the way but you know I
I just sorry I mean this is this is this
is economic craziness and we're not
hearing enough about just how crazy it
is so we'll see what happens I mean
there we are it's gonna be let me tell
you if we we start running deficits 14
and a half dollars we've got very tough
times ahead in my opinion and we lose
the ability to respond when in fact you
can
we get soft
who's next yes yes ma'am
grab that mic yes we can hear I think
the American people would be more than
happy to pay have higher taxes if they
got something back from those taxes if
they had health insurance he had free
education because the Danes the Swedes
and Norwegians and a lot of other people
in this world even outside of
Scandinavia right and then we have to
stop these Wars yeah they're constantly
on yeah we have a hundred and fifty
bases all over the world we have this
unbelievable eight hundred and thirty
eight hundred and thirty seven American
bases in 150 countries that's what we
got out there 837 last count maybe it's
changed a little bit I agree with you
837 American bases not in 50 countries
what are they doing out there
what are we doing out there doesn't seem
to me it's contributing to world peace
and stability and those kinds of things
and a lot of our resources going there
and we're spending seven hundred billion
dollars in the military this year that
can't go for health care and a at least
low-cost University educated college
education for kids and all the kinds of
things that I think most Americans would
support so it's it's it's centered
central door trying to get baths and get
back on track and achieve some degree of
balance between what's going on well but
part of the political process ought to
be to help people get informed yeah go
ahead
how do we get more infrastructure would
you be willing to run a deficit that get
more infrastructure or could you look
I'm a big train man I don't think that's
a secret Randy I was the guy that led
the fight to kill the so-called master
highway plant at metropolitan Boston
which would have paved over the city of
Boston I kid you not I mean destroyed
the city in my opinion it was a long
tenure fight and then thanks to a
sainted man named Thomas B O'Neill jr.
who we know his tip we managed to change
federal law so that all that highway
money could go into public
transportation if the state or the city
wanted and we took full advantage of
that and as a result we invested three
billion dollars of federal highway
dollars in the Boston transit system now
it's got some management problems these
days but I think we can agree that bus
and Scott what at least potentially
ought to be the best public
transportation system in the in the
country and it's done wonders for the
City of Boston Boston today is thriving
because we kill that damn highway
planning and use the money for something
else when Barack Obama first became
president he recommended and proposed
ten billion dollars a year to go into a
national rail passenger rail system ten
billion dollars and that's just a
rounding error the Democratic Congress
approved it first year and it was killed
ever since although there are some
Republicans in the Congress who think
that the National passenger system makes
sense and that's an area where I think
we could get some bipartisan agreement
but the money's there folks
providing we're not throwing it out the
window and all this military stuff 837
American bases in 150 countries and now
we're going to spend a trillion dollars
to modernize
nuclear arsenal doesn't make any sense
to me I don't think we have to raise
taxes to do this we have to make some
judicious cuts in the military budget
and put it into domestic rail which by
the way will not be unhelpful from a
national security standpoint among other
things who's next
yeah you look at a lot of federal races
now it's coming down to a question of
whether or not government is a good
whether it's doing good for the people
or not a lot of conservatives are
running on a platform essentially of
let's eviscerate government the head of
the new head of the federal Consumer
Protection Bureau Mick Mulvaney has
called it an egregious insult to
democracy the the head of the department
was energy energy proposed getting rid
of the Department of Energy when he was
running for the Republican nomination to
the president and from my experience
people who identifies liberal
progressive Democrat everyone affirm it
generally generally believed a
government to be a good thing that does
good things for the citizens and the and
the country I'm just wondering how you
think can bridge that divide you
identify a problem that needs a solution
focus on the left left to generally say
we can use government to solve that
problem folks on the right man say
generally let's get government out of it
let private industry tackle that I'm
just curious how you name can bridge
that seemingly critical divide yeah I
don't think the argument that government
is either too small or too big is
particularly convincing people ask them
whether or not they want to repeal
Medicare what do you think the numbers
will look like on that one ask I mean
ask them that whether not they want to
go into another great recession and
whether or not the government has some
responsibility to do something about
that asking whether or not they want
good schools for their kids and tuition
somewhat less than was it cost to go to
Yale these days what is it
almost selling we have a wonderful
grandson we've got a flock of grandkids
one of them's just started Yale he
started at Tufts 65,000 bucks I paid
$1,100
for room board and tuition that's worth
more college in the 50s now very kind of
a CEO can tell you what the inflation
factor ought to be but it didn't go from
1,100 to 65,000 right don't ask him
whether or not they think government is
too big or too small ask him whether or
not they think these
government-sponsored financed efforts
are important to them why is it that in
so-called red states that I hope the
Democratic Party will stop buying into
this red blue narrative one of the worst
things we've ever done
you know you're right off half the
country from the beginning it's nuts but
you know if you ask and there have been
a number of referenda raising the
minimum wage in so-called red states
they pass with decisive majorities how
come because most of the folks out there
that are voting are middle-class
Americans working trying to support
themselves and their families with a
decent life their incomes haven't gone
up much at all in fact I think 60% of
the American people of making less in
real terms today than they were 20 years
ago then I gotta tell you they don't
want the government to act they may be
frustrated the government is not acting
in ways that they think it should act
but I don't buy this notion that the
vast majority of Americans of a small
government or medium-sized government or
anything else I think they're interested
in the services that government can
provide to make their lives better and
the lives of their kids and grandkids
better and if you put it in those terms
I mean where are they in this tax cut
they were against it why cuz it's a rich
man's tax cut and that doesn't help them
and doesn't make a whole lot of sense
economically either so I don't think
that's the issue the question is how do
you focus now look this has not been a
good year for the Republican Party I
think we can agree I mean they're torn
apart there at each other's throats
descending
thing I don't know what they can do with
this guy in Alabama get selected are
they gonna refuse to seat him and so on
and so forth if the Democratic Party
doesn't clean their clock in the
congressional elections you see next
year then there's something wrong with
us but it's got to be a 50-state 185,000
precinct campaign and I'm serious about
this I'm a huge believer in precinct
based organizing what does that mean a
precinct captain six block capitals
every precinct in the country do you
think 185 thousand precincts in a
country was friends 20 million people
you think the Democratic Party ought to
be able to recruit 185 thousand precinct
captains I would hope so
and I don't care what you're talking
what state red blue or otherwise I mean
you know this is the kind of thing that
this party of mine isn't doing didn't do
if we had done it Donald Trump would be
history we didn't do it we didn't do it
and I've seen it work so many times
Elizabeth Warren never would have been
elected the United States Senate she
hadn't had a precinct akes organization
with a precinct captain every one of the
2157 precincts in Massachusetts and
Kitty 9 will take a little bit of credit
for that because she sat down with us
early on so she got the Dukakis speech
right you got 2,150 of precincts meet
2001 of visionaries and captains each
and we could six-block happens their job
is to make personal contact on an
ongoing basis with every single voting
hustle she did it the polls five days
before the election said the race was
tied or brown was a little ahead she
beat him by 9 percentage points
it was those precinct captains and those
black captains there's no reason Under
the Sun why we can't do this and believe
me you start talking to people on their
doorsteps they're not talking to you
about small government of big government
they're talking about problems that they
face that the communities face and what
we ought to be doing about whose
it's a very serious problem maybe you
ought to spend less time trying to
educate the world on what democracy
isn't get serious about democracy in the
United States which is being which is
where there are serious efforts is all
of you note to curb the ability of folks
especially poor folks Minari folks to
vote and it's serious and we've now got
a Supreme Court in the United States
which has handed sounds have handed down
I mean the Civil Rights Act is
unconstitutional I mean there are a few
lawyers in the room I used to be one
right
how can a Civil Rights Act passed by the
Congress of United States
overwhelmingly with strong bipartisan
support after extensive hearings
how can an extension of the Civil Rights
Act be unconstitutional I don't get it
what is this now we got a new guy in the
Supreme Court trust me he'll be worse
than Scalia my classmate at Law School
of course such will be worse than Scalia
I mean that guy's to the right of Marie
Antoinette I'm serious well that's what
happens you know when you don't win the
presidency here I'm sorry to go on a
great length yeah great that's thank you
going back to building consensus yeah
you know during the Obama
administration's we had one law one
major law and it was passed without a
single Republican vote yeah it was the
health care act eight years with our
laws so the president was forced to to
use orders and directives to make things
work right I'm very afraid that we're
going to end up in the same situation
for at least four years now and my
question is how is it possible to think
of a body that works as internal
diplomats
whoo bridge the gap between Republicans
and Democrats so that we can get
consensus because it's a process as we
all know yeah and it's a it's a
structured process sometimes is that a
wild idea is it is it can the media play
that role and the media is not playing
that role it's playing the oldest a
partisan vote well actually there are
Republicans and Democrats working on
bipartisan issues in the Congress and a
lot you know a lot of legislation passed
in the first two years the Obama
administration just wasn't healthcare
there's a lot of stuff including an
infrastructure bill which passed pretty
decisively and as and as I say hold on
who's calling who's coming tell him I've
already contributed I love these guys
but Elizabeth Warren and a forget her
name a quite conservative Republican
congresswoman from Tennessee have just
been working on getting people with
hearing problems much less expensive
hearing aids now 20 years ago if you
said to me well you know that's an
important issue I just said hearing aids
now the kidding iron eighties not only
are we having you know I find in class
these days I got to move closer to my
students never had to do that before
kitty now wears hearing aids and I don't
have to tell you what you pay for
hearing aids well there's some new
hearing aid that you can get for 300
bucks not 2000 and and the Tennessee
congresswoman and Elizabeth Warren are
working hard to do something about that
the guy from
Texas Cornyn and who's the Democrat I
can't remember is it Chris Murphy no he
no he's from Connecticut but I'm just
wondering
he and are working on at least a modest
effort to control guns is it Chris with
John Koerner yeah huh
really let me say this to you folks my
state has the toughest gun laws in the
country and we have the lowest homicide
rate in the country
I think they're related I think they're
related but these these things I mean
there are people in the Congress who are
looking at opportunities to find common
ground well Olympia was but we see
Olympia was one of those moderate
Republicans who you know was deeply
committed to universal health care now
for a variety of reasons I think the
Democrats badly mishandled her she could
have been a she could have been a very
decisive vote here in a number of ways
and she wanted to be and without getting
in the details of that I mean but she
was the kind of person that you know I
mean I work with with great Republicans
I am even today bill weld was my
successor
now we haven't a practice law together
in fact I supervised him when he was a
young associate my law firm and he and
now are working hard to convince the new
governor that we ought to finally
connect north and south station by rail
and have a fully integrated regional
rail system in not only eastern
Massachusetts but New England Wells my
ally on this he and I are working on
MASS MoCA and north adams which is not
only a great success we turn empty
factory buildings it's all of us
succeeded each other you know a great
Museum of Contemporary Art but now we're
talking about turning North Adams in
doing a Center for the Arts seriously
you look for common ground you look for
people that you can can work with as
this kind of thing and it is happening
but you're right we're not hearing much
about it in the press which is covering
this daily Gong Show at the White House
you know every day but you have to keep
working at that okay I just I think it's
it's so important that if you're in
government that you you do that and I
hope we can yeah long-term ism into
legislators and administration's like
public debts Social Security and
problems like this with difficulty but
you keep working at it and trust me if
you set the stage for this I mean took a
long time for us to get off this highway
thing in Massachusetts and not only to
emphasize public transportation but to
do so in a way which would help revive
our older industrial communities which
were in terrible shape when I first was
elected the mid 70s we had unemployment
rates in in the in the older mills
cities the lols the hay rules the new
Bedford's the fall rivers in the 20s not
anymore
holes one of the great model cities why
well a couple of Greeks named Duke
åkesson Tsongas went to work and
convinced people that we should invest
as a quarter of a billion dollars in
state money and Lowell but let me tell
you something Lowell today is a model
for an old industrial community is now
revived and it's doing exceedingly well
and we're doing or trying to do that in
all of our other older urban communities
still have work to do long range yeah
but we somehow managed I think to
convince people that this was an
important priority that government could
do it not by itself obviously but that
it was an important part of the the mix
and in point of fact those old mill
cities of coming back in a remarkable
way by the way in case you've missed it
cities are coming back isn't that
amazing
you're coming back when I first got
elected the legislature folks you know
Boston was practically dying
so a lot of other cities in Connecticut
and elsewhere you know it was a if the
city was racist it was anti-semitic it
was divided it was angry Boston Harbor
was a sore I mean I could go on and on
on not these days was pretty strong
broad bipartisan support so there are
people in Congress working at this and
one of the things we ought to be doing
is trying to encourage them to do so and
I think we can but it's always a piano
short term long term can you convince
people that that they ought to be
working now on things that is one of the
reasons why infrastructure is so
important it's nothing short term about
infrastructure and it has a profound
effect on how you grow what you know how
where investment goes and all that kind
of stuff um it's critical if you can
convince people that a long-term
infrastructure program makes sense and
they'll invest in it it'll have profound
effects maybe one or two more questions
then we'll wrap up yeah youth will be
served
go ahead one of the kalos Athenians who
weren't participating actively in the
politics community you remember Ethiopia
which for those of you don't speak Greek
needless to say is the root word for
idiot the Ortiz was the word he used
right anyway and you know I think I
think that is very much embodied by by
your generation serving military you
practice law you served in government in
public service and it seems like that
has been you know very much part of the
American tradition for me yeah Hamilton
to Webster - yeah - Roosevelt I think
now it's beginning to decline I like I
mean I'm not sure Reagan exactly was a
statesman and at this point the Trump it
seems to be like now we're just outright
rejecting
with like people anymore I don't agree
with you I don't agree with you my
students these days are really hopped up
about public service thanks to Donald
Trump no it's really kind of interesting
I've got kids porn in my office every
day we want to sit down and talk about
how they get into public service I have
hundreds I've been teaching for 27 years
I've got hundreds and hundreds of former
students who are out there doing great
stuff one of them just got elected to
Congress in California his name is Jimmy
Gomez who was Jimmy Gomez the youngest
of six in a family of Mexican immigrants
who came to the United States illegally
in the 1970s got amnesty under the
Reagan amnesty bill in case people have
forgotten this in 1986 they settled in
Riverside whose mayor by the way is also
a former student of mine and a terrific
mayor who's now pairing up religious
congregations with homeless people rusty
Bailey is going to have a religious
organization adopting every single
homeless person in Riverside this is
gonna cost the city anything anyway back
to Gomez so Goya's ends up in Riverside
almost dies at the age of six because
they don't have health insurance and
they don't get him to the hospital on
time and graduates from high schools
working at Target or something and
somehow took a course at the Riverside
Community College you got to be because
somebody said to him you want to enroll
here and he did and then transfer to
UCLA and I get him and of course I teach
in California policy issues some about
this kid so I bring them in have a
conversation I say you interested in
politics well if you haven't been apart
no you interested yeah I kind of
interested Jimmy Thomas graduated magna
from UCLA went to the Kennedy School and
got a masters at Harvard went back out
to Los Angeles went to work for the
unions went to work for a member of
Congress ran for the assembly from East
Los Angeles got elected
and in the special election to fill
Xavier Becerra vacant seat it was now
the Attorney General Gomez won by 20
percentage points it sounds pretty good
to me but you guys have got to get
involved that's the important thing and
I must say to you that in a crazy kind
of way Trump seems to have stimulated an
enormous interest in at least the kids
on teaching these days on both coasts by
the way in public service but they need
some guy to say these those of us who've
been in the business to take him in hand
and say to him hey t you can do this you
know it's the most open political system
in the world folks I mean what was a
Greek kid in the town of Brookline doing
running for office I don't know you know
I hardly had a big ethnic vote in the
town of Brookline Massachusetts right so
I ran for Town Meeting from a precinct
rang every doorbell stood in front of a
public place for 13 hours get elected I
mean that's where it all started you can
do the same you can do the same question
what do I think of this what if I see
him I'm gonna tell him to go to Glacier
National Park in a hurry because in 10
years there won't be any glaciers there
and I'm gonna ask him whether or not he
has any conception of what is going on
it's very interesting and I'll conclude
with this one of the interesting things
that's happened is that governors states
and mayors and local communities with a
lot of help from the former mayor of New
York who happens to be a native of
Medford Massachusetts whose family
couldn't buy a house in Medford
Massachusetts when he was a kid because
he was Jewish they were Jewish and they
had to go through a straw to get the
house that's Mike bloomer
anyway Bloomberg has an Institute now
which he's supporting he's very
committed to doing something about
climate change and that Institute with
you know Jerry Brown and number
the governor's and and and mayor's have
basically said to the world hey don't
pay any attention to that guy we hope
little of us and were for the Paris
agreement and we're gonna do everything
we can to implement it kind of
interesting what was the last time that
happened and by the way notice that
while all of this nonsense is going on
in Washington state and local
governments are for the most part out
there doing their jobs and reflecting I
think a lot more of the values that are
represented in a room like this and I
represented and Trump telling meantime
the business is going south you know so
maybe he'll pay attention to that as
well but you know the look call is gone
I mean I'm sorry I you know i but I won
West Virginia by 12 percentage points
and I got a lot of votes from coal
miners but coal is gone you know and and
the private sector is leaving called not
using coal anymore and this guy in China
whatever you think of his politics it's
just announced that they're gonna be all
electric by 2030 2040 you know so I
continue to be fairly optimistic when I
share the same feelings most of us we
have when we wake up in the morning
discover that we've got another tweet
and it's another crazy something and oh
sorry anyway it's been great fun being
with you to the young people
particularly I hope I hope you'll get
into this business and get into it
seriously and and encourage your fellow
Greek Americans you've got a great
heritage and and I think a great
responsibility and I hope you'll follow
up on that Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]